[Music]
welcome to swipe from the sunny ish
South of England here's a little glimpse
at what we'll be bringing you on this
week's program
Alex checks out the tech saving Tudor
treasures I meet the man behind a
jet-powered suit and get a look inside
his lab and we've got the new fighting
game from the makers of Mortal Kombat
they say that battle changes to I don't
know what it is about Wiltshire but this
is the second week in a row I've come
here to film an episode of swipe
featuring men who can fly last week it
was all about a wingsuit this week a
jet-powered one that's coming up a
little bit later on because first we're
going to check in with Alex who's been
getting the most modern of history
lessons he's been to a mansion that
regularly hosted Henry the eighth and
his various why's to see how they're
using the latest technology to save the
building and its treasures
the vine a 16th century tudor powerhouse
nestled in the Hampshire countryside a
treasure of the National Trust its story
is one of challenge change and survival
so in Tudor England this walk would have
been very different than I'm taking now
this grand mansion behind me would have
stretched right the way down to the
water and was built by one of the most
powerful men that Henry the Eighth
needed to keep onside his Lord
Chamberlain and Henry himself would have
come here first with Catherine of Aragon
then his ill-fated second wife and
Berlin but as you can see over the
centuries the house has been locked down
rebuilt adjusted and at the moment vital
work costing over five million pounds
and using the latest tech is taking
place up there on the roof in order to
save this building for future
generations centuries of storms have
taken their toll with leaks from the
crumbling roof threatening the artifacts
inside and when the tiles stripped off
much of the decay is easily noticeable
but the threat posed by moisture under
the surface is effectively invisible
traditionally you would have to have
burrowed into the structure to really
examine it but not anymore
so the higher tech things we've got are
for example this trace it which is an
optical profile ometer so what's that
what's that something like me in simple
terms that really gives you a good image
of the surface but it also renders that
into 3d techniques like this used by
heritage scientists allow you to
effectively see through the walls
without leaving a scratch we use a
number of different microwave techniques
to detect moisture at depth within the
wall this is a handheld version of these
and it's very simple you simply place it
against the material it comes up with a
reading and then you can map moisture
distributions across a wall very easily
using something like this so if you like
what we're able to do is not only see
inside the wall but also detect the very
first symptoms of deterioration before
it becomes a problem
the focus might be repair work but it's
also a unique chance for archaeologists
to use the science of dendrochronology
or tree ring dating to calculate
precisely when the house was built what
you do is you'll end up with a sort of
finger sized sample these have
to be cleaned under a laboratory and
then they run through a microscope that
records each of these growth rings and
if those are then run through a computer
program you can actually relate them to
Timbers of known day when you get a
match you can actually determine when
the actual felling date is for that ring
at the end
we've never been quite sure of the exact
date when these buildings were
constructed but with these precise dates
I think we got about three of these
Timbers that have all dated 1526 on
Henri's many visits it was likely the
affairs of state on his mind and not the
state of the roof but without this vital
work today there was a very real danger
that what remains of this house could
have been lost Alex Morgan sky news
stick around for our games review in
just a few minutes we're throwing you
into a futuristic space battle but
before that now for the reason I'm at a
farm in Wiltshire you could actually
call it a testing site for this
this video of British inventor Richard
browning testing his jet-powered suit
has been watched more than a million
times the ex city trader and former
Royal Marine reservist has no formal
engineering training but he does have a
huge amount of curiosity as I discovered
when visiting him at home in Wiltshire
yes so this is the the lab this is where
I've spent quite a bit of time over the
last 18 months developing the jet suit
is this the very suit that you wear that
is yeah we suspend it all in that place
just so you can connect it up and test
it but yeah that is that is pretty much
all the equipment you you have a pair of
engines on each arm so that's one arm
there's the other arm and these ones
actually go around my where my waist at
the back each engine then is plugged
into into one of these brains and then
we get up here this is a holographic
heads-up display helmet from the company
called daiquiri it's a pretty neat piece
of kit it displays all the engine data
and fuel consumption data that gets
wirelessly transmitted by the suit so
it's it's a very neat way of being able
to monitor the system and monitor our
fuel so it's giving you information on
the inside of the visor yeah it's kind
of hovering in a like a fighter pilot
kind of heads-up display if you'd like
to have a look and see what I see when
I'm flying it this is heavy how much
would this cost daiquiri sell these now
for about $15,000 this is the only black
one in existence they're very kindly
built sir a really quite customized one
okay I think I think maybe it's a bit
big for me the suit cost Richard less
than a hundred thousand pounds to create
but the hundreds and hundreds of
man-hours from him and his team he says
have been the greatest expense and if
you're wondering why he even began the
project if I'm really honest it was the
starting point was just have an enormous
amount of fun taking on the challenge of
human flight but from a very different
perspective taking it on from the idea
of leveraging the human mind and body
and then adding to that rather than
putting the human form in a flight
vehicle you know what would what would
be possible if you really leveraged the
mind and body capability so time to find
out more about Rich's mind and body
capabilities we're heading to a nearby
farm his testing ground a few minutes
away
it's suiting up time and there's a lot
to consider oh I forgot one of those GSE
things again
never mind it'll all work perfectly Deb
can I have your help in a second
Richard's wife seems to be used to this
part of the operation helping him buckle
up and get ready does this not worry you
it did initially when he first told me
about the project and what was aiming to
do and but since I've been following it
the last few months I understand how it
works a bit more it is not as bad as it
looks and I might even possibly have
another go myself with the arm engines
at some point that's a fireproof suit
you're wearing yeah yes it is there's a
there's a fireproof base layer
underneath all of this that's just
really a precaution even though the fuel
is usually diesel paraffin or jet fuel
it's really not particularly dangerous
it doesn't turn into a vapor cloud it
doesn't suddenly spontaneously ignite
it's all very much sealed up in the fuel
tank system warming up the engines takes
about 90 seconds and it's noisy
you can smell the fuel and feel the
intense heat here we go
richard says the suit could fly
thousands of feet high and at speeds of
several hundred miles per hour the only
thing stopping him from doing that is
the danger risk he controls the
direction of the suit by adjusting where
he points the engines it's a very
strange feeling a bit like riding a bike
in three dimensions you don't really
think about what you're doing when
you're riding a bike it just happens the
balance is quite natural Richards team
is now working on a second
more advanced version of the suit and
even a children's option that apparently
won't involve jet engines but still aims
to give wearers a superhero feel
Richard's taking a breather and
refueling but we've got more action for
you now because it's video games time
here's Lucy with her pick of the latest
releases injustice 2 hits this week
which is a fighting game based in the DC
Universe so you've probably heard of
Mortal Kombat and this game comes from
the creators of Mortal Kombat and it
basically it's a fighting game but with
DC characters so you know you've got
Superman Batman the Joker
Brainiac scarecrow Catwoman Supergirl I
mean I could go on there's a massive
roster of fighters that you can play
with it has an awesome story mode the
heroes and villains are kind of fighting
and working together a bit of an uneasy
alliance to try and get earth back on
track it's an awesome fighting game it
has its really cool mechanic called the
Gear RPG system where after you play you
unlock different kind of different items
to wear and they can affect your base
stats you can of course take take the
fight online and play against your
friends so if you like fighting games or
even if you just love DC characters then
definitely give injustice to it work
the search is a Dark Souls esque
third-person game so when I say Dark
Souls ask I mean that the game is
difficult and requires you to really
focus on your enemies you can't just go
in all guns or swords blazing you have
to really study the enemy movements and
kind of attack accordingly so the search
is very similar to that except instead
of being in a high fantasy setting it's
in the future we have depleted all of
Mother Earth's resources and things are
getting a little bit hairy so it's
basically you fighting against the
industry that has ruined the earth and
in order to do that you have this kind
of exoskeleton suit that you can modify
and upgrade and you can put your talent
points into the fighting style that you
like basically if you fancy a bit of a
challenge then I definitely give the
surgical Farpoint is a PlayStation VR
title so Sony launched their PlayStation
VR late last year and it was a big
success and now they are continuing to
support it with titles and PowerPoint is
a VR only title so you have your headset
and you also have this new controller
called the aim controller and it
basically looks like a bent bit of
plastic tubing but it sort of replicates
a gun and it's basically a first-person
shooter game you are on a space station
that crash lands and there's loads of
bugs everywhere so it's basically a
little bit Starship Troopers II so you
know if you're afraid of bugs maybe skip
this one but it's kind of nice to be
able to see like full games on the
PlayStation VR system a lot of the time
previously we've just had little demos
and now with games like resident evil 7
that you can play completely in VR and
now Farpoint Sony are really investing
into this technology so if you fancy
giving it a go then power point is the
one for you you know hi
[Music]
well that's it for this week's show from
here in Wiltshire thank you for joining
us once again and don't forget you can
catch up with any of our episodes on
demand in all the usual places and why
not follow us on twitter at sky news
light then you can see what we get our
to throughout the week I'll be back
again next time see you there bye bye
[Music]